[Music]
you are watching the press preview now a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with journalist and author rachel shabby
and editor of the jewish chronicle jake
wallace simons so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
vladimir putin's warning to the west
your sanctions are akin to an act of war
that's on the front of the observer
meanwhile the telegraph looks at defense
secretary ben wallace's threat to mr
putin that to test the uk would result
in some form of a response
the mirror leads where the russian
soldiers are breaking a ceasefire in
mario poll with the headline clear off
back to russia
merciless putin shells evacuees reads
the front of the sunday times as they
too lead with the situation in mariopol
the express quotes foreign secretary liz
trust that the war in ukraine represents
the struggle of our generation
the star claims that the russian leader
is dying of cancer
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we're joined tonight by rachel
shabby and jake wallace simons welcome
to you both good evening let's start
with the times front page and their
headline there merciless putin shells
evacuees and this is the ceasefire that
essentially wasn't rachel
that's right so there was supposed to be
a ceasefire in mariopol
uh which is a southern port city in
ukraine
and just as it was taking effect uh
russian strikes began um so it was
instantly broken so
uh anyone who was trying to leave the
city which has already been besieged
could not do so it's absolutely
heartbreaking to watch things like this
take place but like also has to be said
no surprise for anyone who watched uh
russians actions in syria a few years
ago
um but
obviously if there is a ceasefire
bad enough that it's broken but if there
is a ceasefire then it kind of implies
if um there is an allowance for an
evacuet for a human
to evacuate people who can and wish to
leave and also to replenish supplies
because food and medical supplies are
very very low in that city
it doesn't bode well um it suggests that
there is tragically far worse to come
in that area
oh we're we're um you're breaking up a
little bit there rachel but let's bring
out jake in now and um looking at that
picture on the front page of the times
with uh those looks like hundreds of
people sheltering under a bridge this
breaking of the ceasefire just
reiterates the fact that there are no
rules there are no rules by which
president putin is working
that's right what we're really seeing is
uh is a very old-fashioned kind of war a
return to the total war that we haven't
seen in europe since you know 1945
in which civilians are seen as
legitimate targets before the geneva
convention um and russia will just do
whatever it takes
to win this war and rachel rightly
pointed out the syrian war when russia
used similarly brutal carpet bombing
tactics on
cities like aleppo and now we're seeing
those activities once again being rolled
out
in ukraine because
the russian war machine is clearly uh
not up to the job of doing proper you
know a proper siege and and street by
street urban warfare instead it's
seeking to stand back and just you know
bomb these cities into oblivion and as
one commentator said recently creating a
desert and calling it peace and so you
know these are obviously very very
dangerous and hugely worrying times that
are taking us back decades upon decades
to an era that we all thought that we
had seen the last of and sadly it's
rearing its ugly head once again uh in
in the era of vladimir putin
and for the moment we're we're seeing
that uh nato is um not agreeing to a
no-fly no-fly zone but various countries
are
ramping up the sanctions against russia
and increasingly worrying that president
putin is now saying that the sanctions
imposed against his regime he's seeing
that as a declaration of war rachel
yeah the rhetoric over the last few days
from putin and from others it has to be
said has been absolutely appalling and
horrifying and quite terrifying just
this constant ratcheting up that's going
on
these sanctions are unprecedented i mean
we've never seen
countries that wouldn't usually partake
in sanctions against russia japan
singapore they have done so this time
and so it's no surprise that putin is is
lashing out um they will
have a choke hold on the russian economy
they will start to take effect but yes
you're right that the the language that
he is using
um recently and just in the last few
weeks been
absolutely horrifying and the observer
also picking up on that
line and it's
it's it is chilling that this warning
has been delivered to the west one
wonders what
his response to the west might might be
if he's saying that this is an act of
war what will he do next jake
yes i mean you know putin uh has long
adhered to the lenin idea of or the
metaphor of having a bayonet and
sticking it into the other side if you
feel steel withdrawal if you feel
softness or mush keep pushing and he's
keep he's been keeping testing us um uh
you know year on year uh via his actions
in in crimea some years ago in georgia
um and now he's felt that he you know
can take action in ukraine he's seeing
where the line is that we're going to
respond and the extension of that is uh
this rhetoric you know citing the
nuclear threat you know saying that us
supporting ukraine by weapons and trying
to put pressure on russia via sanctions
is akin to an act of war you know he's
trying to put more and more pressure on
nato and on the west but i think that
it's a great mistake
to look at our response to russian
aggression i.e sanctions and look at our
defensive position i.e you know nato and
the building up of forces there as being
the cause of any kind of aggression or
any kind of warfare or conflict the the
blame for this lies squarely with
vladimir putin
nato didn't invade any other country
this is purely his fault
russia has invaded ukraine we mustn't
mistake uh you know nato's defensive
actions and the west's defensive actions
against russia as any kind of act of
aggression we are purely
you know defensive and we've been pushed
to it by by russia's aggression
meanwhile the defense secretary ben
wallace in the sunday telegraph is uh
quoted as saying don't test us uh that's
his warning to vladimir putin not
a military um response he's suggesting
but that they can give the ukrainians
much more in by way of uh weapons
rachel
well that's right um
you have to wonder about the wisdom of
this though i mean this is just more
escalation isn't it um the defense
secretary saying you know you shouldn't
test us and you've seriously
underestimated
um the country's resolve
well
fine but
the uk and other countries have made it
clear that there will be no
military operation from any other
country in ukraine uh there will there
won't be a no-fly zone because that has
to be that is an escalation that no one
is willing to countenance
devastating as it is to watch ukraine go
through
fine assault just being bombarded um
[Music]
relentlessly
in the most appalling way by russian
forces
it is simply the case that there isn't
going to be
an international military response and
that being the
reality we we need to we need to be
talking about negotiation uh
escalation of rhetoric
is really not going to get us anywhere
jake do you agree with uh rachel that
this bellicose approach and this tone
from bel wallace is not what's needed at
this precise time
i don't agree no i think that what we
need to show uh to valid putin is that
he cannot intimidate us he cannot
intimidate the west as a whole and he
cannot throw his weight around um with
impunity by raising the specter of
nuclear war i mean you know he's not the
only country in the world with nuclear
weapons
nato as a conjoined uh force
has overwhelmingly greater ability to
destroy russia than vice versa as long
as we act with united resolved now i'm
not calling for war don't get me wrong
but what i'm saying is that putin's
modus operandis has proved as he's
proved year in year out is to test the
opposition and whenever he finds
weakness he then exploits that and
history has taught us that when dealing
with tyrants and despots and dictators
who have designed on on other countries
on invading them and occupying them and
so forth the only thing that stops them
is a a determined result resolute show
of of strength and that's what we must
show as a united front to to uh valerie
putin
right now so he isn't tempted to push
this any further we're gonna leave it
there
we're gonna leave it there just before
the break uh rachel will be back but uh
coming up we'll take a look at the
sunday people their headline you can
stick your oil vlad
do stay with us
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me journalist and
author rachel shabby and editor of the
jewish chronicle jake wallace simons
there they both are welcome back to you
both um let's have a look at the sunday
express and uh liz trust pictured there
saying that this uh is the struggle of
our generation and it is actually a
struggle to protect western values jake
yes quite quite a powerful phrase there
the struggle of our generation i think
that it is quite apt you know for all of
my lifetime
and that of many other people we've got
used to this post-war settlement by
which uh we've been living in in peace
with relative security all of the wars
that we have waged have taken place many
thousands of miles from our shores with
no direct repercussions on us leaving us
free to become preoccupied with issues
of identity and race and colonialism and
all the other things that we've been
at the indulgence to talk about i guess
and yet suddenly while we busy ourselves
thinking about those things um you know
1945 has come by again
um not too many miles away from our
homes and this has taken us all by
surprise i think there's a sort of
cultural shock that's gone through the
west as a whole suddenly realizing that
that reality could be rather more
serious than we've all gotten used to
over over the last decades and i guess
the real question now is are we up to it
are we up to facing up to this very real
a very horrendous struggle
and challenge that's coming from the
east and do we have the resolve and the
grit to really do what it takes to face
down putin and stand up for our values
and i guess that's what liz trust was
pointing to this phrase the struggle of
our generation do we have what it takes
to meet that challenge but rachel um as
we've seen thus far um it doesn't look
as though there will be any uh military
confrontation so to
president putin this might seem very
weak he's just facing more and more
sanctions
i mean i don't think the sanctions are
weak by any means i think they're pretty
punitive
um and are likely to take effect uh but
to to speak to
this sort of defining moment
um
analysis of liz trust i mean i i think
that i would say in response to that
that everything is connected so
you know
we've been fighting wars that haven't
impacted us really well you know the the
invasion of
followed out that region
uh created
um
you know
the conditions for islamic state uh
created the conditions for russia to
invade syria and hone its barbaric um
military
skill for one of a better word there
our dependency on oil and energy and our
reluctance to shift to renewables has
meant that you know we are funding putin
right now because of our energy
dependency there we've got 30 years of
neoliberalism that has created uh what's
known as a london laundromat for russian
oligarch money again propping up putin
um if this is a defining moment then
maybe we can realize that our
sequences and we have helped create this
monster
that is putin that is in no way saying
that we are responsible for
his com his invasion of ukraine and the
appalling acts of that we've seen in the
last week
um but things are inter
you know maybe we can start to de-link
them now yeah you broke up a little bit
uh there rachel um but i think your
pointer came across and there's there's
much support for ukraine and people
wanting to demonstrate that that support
um here the sunday people picking up on
the story of the british dockers
refusing to unload russian oil from a
tanker and that's in the show of
solidarity with ukraine the headline you
can stick your oil vlad jake
that's right this is quite um quite
quite a powerful story because it brings
together the idea that not just
governments in the west are opposed
against putin also ordinary people as
well i mean i think that you know as far
back as i can remember this is the most
unifying cause that i've seen
um in our country you know everybody is
is flying ukraine or many people are
flying ukrainian flags there are very
very few voices sticking up for putin
and putting russia's
point of view or the official russian uh
authority's point of view um you know
the cause of ukraine has unified this
country behind them it's unified the
west and unified you know europe
and here we can see that dockers
refusing to
offload russian oil
is mirroring the widespread sanctions
that are being meted out against the
putin regime and also all the different
commercial companies from apple to
burberry who are pulling out of russia
as well all with one goal to try to make
vladimir putin feel the pain and the
consequences of his actions without
causing us to have to go into action and
that's the vital thing and the fact that
everybody is united from from dockers to
politicians and back again shows that
the west really does speak with one
voice at the moment and we need to
really build upon that to pile the
pressure on putin to make him pull back
and rachel very quickly just uh picking
up on that theme of uh businesses also
pulling out burberry we've had visa
tonight um that feeding into your
thought that the sanctions and and the
efforts to isolate russia
will have an effect
well it remains to be seen we don't know
whether they'll have an effect because
we've never seen anything on this scale
before um but i i guess that the the
main thing here is removing um
sorry rachel we're moving
i just say removing his support base
amongst the oligarchs and also removing
his capacity
this awful wall